i don't call leader of the opposition
kia stammer
[Applause]
uh thank you mr speaker i'd like to
thank the prime minister for advanced
copy of his statement
um and to welcome him back to these
shores
they say that absence makes the heart
grow fonder
so i wish you the best of luck in seeing
if that works as a party management
strategy
mr speaker
mr speaker it's been 131 days since
russia's illegal invasion of ukraine
131 days of war at the heart of our
continent
131 days of putin trying to cower his
neighbors
131 days of brave ukrainian resistance
i've always said
that this house
and britain's allies must put aside our
differences in other areas and show
unity in our opposition to putin's
aggression
and we have
driven by the inspiration provided by
the people of ukraine
and the leadership and courage of
president zielinski
as this conflict reaches its sixth month
and drags on in eastern ukraine it's
important that we don't think our job is
done
putin would like nothing better
than for us to lose our focus for the
grip of sanctions to weaken
for military aid to ukraine to dry up
or for cracks to appear in the unity of
putin's opponents
so i welcome the progress made at the
nato summit last week
and congratulate our good friends in
finland and sweden for their formal
invitation to join the nato alliance
and of course ukraine on securing their
candidate status to join the european
union
i hope these processes can be concluded
as quickly as possible to send a clear
message to putin
that his war has permanently changed the
european landscape
but not in the way that he planned
i also welcome the commitment to
strengthen our collective deterrent
capabilities
i've seen firsthand how british
personnel are working with other nato
forces to ensure the collective shield
that's protected us for three quarters
of a century remains as strong as ever
so i welcome the agreement on the new
nato force model
ensuring over 300 000 conventional
troops will be at high readiness across
europe
can i ask the prime minister
how this agreement will affect british
military planning
and if he believes our extra commitments
can be met
given his cuts to uk troop numbers
the commitment made at the g7 of further
financial support for ukraine is also
welcome
as our plans to help ukraine with
post-war reconstruction through an
international conference
mr speaker there could be no clearer
case that aid spending makes britain
more secure and prevents the need for
military spending in the future which
demonstrates the folly in reducing our
aid commitments at a time of global
instability
i'm pleased that unity was on display at
both the nato summit and the g7 summit
but i am concerned about current unity
within the commonwealth
the commonwealth is a valuable and
important institution for this country
it isn't just a symbol of our past
it's important for our future
providing us with influence in all parts
of the world
but in recent years there have been
serious signs of strain
when many major commonwealth countries
abstained at the u.n over russia's
invasion of ukraine
the summit should have been an
opportunity to widen diplomatic
coalition
against putin
instead the prime minister waged a
divisive campaign against the
commonwealth leadership that ended up in
a humiliating diplomatic failure
only illustrating his embarrassing lack
of influence
instead of investing in aid that
strengthens the alliance he's cut it
instead of upholding the rule of law
that should define the commonwealth he
reneges on treaties that he signed
undermining britain's moral and
political credibility
when we need our word to carry trust
my fear is simple the vacuum we leave
behind will be quickly filled
not by those who share our values
but by those who seek to destroy them we
cannot let that happen in ukraine
we cannot let that happen anywhere
thank you mr speaker